you've known tiger jim gray for how
since he was how old
since he was a very young man seven or
eight years old so
i've known tiger almost four decades
yeah okay
and and you know john you've known him
from the tour
everybody that i've talked to loves him
he's been great for the game i've known
him since he was 13 years old
wow wow he's he's the most incredible
kid i've ever met in my life
i mean the talent everything that goes
with tiger woods
is just incredible i i said he would
break jack nicklaus record
probably 20 years ago unbelievable and
and you've had a great career yourself
um jim it looks i mean for a golfer i
mean he's had
these other injuries he's had the back
problems
certainly this isn't going to help his
golf game
but he's been playing really well since
he's come back from the last surgery
right until this recent surgery yeah but
nobody's ever going to forget to
2019 when he came back and won the may
the major championship at augusta
national to win
that masters after not winning a major
for 11 years and
and to come back from where he was the
five back surgeries the knee surgeries
uh the infidelity scandal the dui
it's the greatest individual comeback in
the history of sports to be from that
peak to that valley
back to the top and now we're just
praying that he's able to
get through these injuries and lead a
normal life and
and full recovery uh but it's the
greatest comeback ever the
greatest team come back was the patriots
down 23 uh 28 to 3.
uh now you're talking about another one
that but this is the greatest individual
come back and
and now we're just all pulling for him
to live a normal life
you know now you're talking about tom
brady too you know one of the things i
love about golf john and i
and i've i've watched your career and
it's always fun to see you at a
tournament you just
you know you bring an energy to the to
the game that that i just find
infectious as hell and the pressure
though when you're out there and you've
won let's see go going through your
record pb
pga champion ship as a as a rookie
the british open you won the pressure on
a golfer
just to put in a three foot putt has got
to be enormous
i don't know sean cause it never really
bothered me it never has bothered me
i go play golf i'm kind of a blue collar
guy
so you know if i made a putt back in a
day you know a 10-footer to
to make 20 grand okay i just wanted to
make the putt
and i still am the same way i don't i
don't have a career like tiger
i don't think a lot of people ever will
but
i play golf for fun and i have fun
and that's why i just have so many
people that want to play golf with me
because all i want to do is have fun i'm
not
you know i i've had my day you know i
wanted to be number one back in the day
when the rankings come out
in 95 if when i won the british open
i would have got so many ranking points
but it didn't come out till 96. promise
me this
you know so promise me you'll play with
me and jim
gray that would be that's a bucket list
item for me
so anyway we're praying for tiger
tonight thanks guys